welcome to Startalk Neil deGrasse Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist this
is a cosmic queries edition cosmic
queries in the corona verse this is our
continuing series of star talks that
focus on the human condition during the
pandemic and Chuck Chuck nice my co-host
hey buddy you know I can't do this
without you you know that's a madam I'm
happy to be here I don't think to do
right now this is great and today we're
focusing on mental health previously we
talked about the virus specifically now
we're talking about how we're dealing
with it and you know there's only one
person we can reach out for only one
only one has a and B only one welcome
back to Startalk thanks I'm glad to be
here but the pressure is on
okay we didn't we didn't find you
wandering in the streets you are a
neuroscientist you're professional
therapists and you're based at MO Sinai
Hospital upper Upper East Side of New
York City of Manhattan and so we we've
come to you for so many things who would
have thought you'd be that useful to us
[Laughter]
issue but now suddenly so on the
landscape there's like the freakout
moment when it went from just an
outbreak to a pandemic and that must
have had emotional cost and then there's
everybody's like on lockdown now if you
live in a big house maybe that's not a
problem but you know we live in New York
City and apartments are small so I've
read articles about this it's not
working out in a lot of household you
know and so yeah is there anything I'm
missing in that list for what we should
be thinking about so in a way it's sort
of the perfect storm
in that initially we had you know we
call the fight-or-flight response right
the panic the fear it's really a
physiologic response to threat some
people in the initial
stages of this we're looking to fleet
right like I got to get out of here but
there was really in some ways nowhere to
go right it's a global problem and then
this people started panicking panic
buying and reaching for safety right you
know toilet paper for some reason became
the safety resource nothing makes me
feel safer it's like oh my god we're all
gonna die but I'll do it with a very
pristine so this this panic response and
then and that kind of as we were in this
for longer and longer resolves a bit but
then these new issues arise right one
person I'll never forget this tweet they
said like this is either gonna end for
people who are married in murder or
divorce right yeah like people if you
already had issues they become
exacerbated now if you take people
already had mental health issues whether
it was anxiety or depression now you're
throwing in isolation you know work used
to be an outlet for people right a way
to maybe get away to get away from bad
relationships but now you're all stuck
in a house together so anything that was
already there is exacerbated and then in
addition people who weren't dealing with
mental health issues but perhaps they
had a vulnerability suddenly these
mental health issues start to arise but
just one other thing I want to mention
which is a really interesting phenomenon
that I've talked about and written about
a bit is that I have some patients and
so did my colleagues who previously had
OCD or obsessive compulsive disorder
afraid of contamination and ending in
social anxiety and and just a subset of
them actually have gotten better during
the pandemic a bit better suddenly
they're not alone suddenly you know
they're not the odd person out they were
already we're engaging in these
behaviors of washing hands and being
very conscientious about germs and now
everybody else is doing it when you say
they're not alone you mean their
behavior is no longer odd exactly
because others have joined in in their
peculiarities and so now it's a
normalizing force on their conduct
really I think
I think really what they're experiencing
is they're looking at everybody going
and people with social anxiety I mean
this is great there's no pressure to
have to go out you know they have a
perfect excuse to not engage so for
interestingly some people it's
particular in xiety disorders have
actually been more relaxed during the
pandemic
it doesn't affect everybody in the same
way okay so there's another dimension
here which is the people who have been I
think it especially affects people whose
livelihoods were sort of outlawed during
the pandemic they have restaurant owners
and restaurant workers or for me the top
of that list but there's the list is
long and they there's a huge industry
there and some of them in some states
have never rebelled is that would you
say that's a psychological state or is
it just a normal yeah of course you're
gonna Rebell cuz you're somebody took
the government took away your livelihood
there are a few issues first obviously
the economic stress is an added factor
for people there is also as one some
people react with denial you know it's
so overwhelming and also the uncertainty
you know when is it gonna end
what if we don't have a vaccine you know
that so should we have these
psychological defense mechanisms
what if M is denial oh you know what
it's not even that bad of a problem it's
just like the flu like let's just go
back to life as normal and almost it's
kind of a denial
it's obviously motivated by these very
good reasons you know they're in
economic hardship and they can use all
that to rationalize but a lot of it is
you have to in order to do that and
remain without having to call cognitive
dissonance you have to downplay the
threat
oh it's not so bad of a threat yes
justify yeah justify your behavior this
will go away just it'll be like a
miracle it'll go away
it's so heavy you raise it the
fascinating point what you're saying is
since we are thinking creatures
emotional thinking
creatures the juxtaposition of those two
dimensions of what it is to be human
have fascinated consequences so that
what you're saying if I understand
correctly is you can't just up and say
we need to go back to work because I got
to make money you have to distort
evidence or distort statements made by
scientists so that like you said it
doesn't conflict within you and so they
got it simultaneously say it's not so
bad and be in denial that that's that's
that's a peculiar manifestation of human
thought that's the human condition
because we don't have these self
protective mechanisms of our ego right
we don't want to say oh I'm a bad person
like me going out let's say without a
mask I'm gonna kill somebody's
grandmother right nobody wants to say
I'm so in order to get away from that
thinking you're a bad person you have to
change the narrative to justify your
behavior to protect your ego so you
think oh no I'm a good person because
actually there is no real threat and I'm
not threatening you know the lives of
other people or else you'd have to say
you're a bad person but the ego protects
against that so Heather how much of this
is cultural what you guys just discuss
because in some cultures it's seen as a
responsibility like I gotta wear a mask
because I have to protect the collective
whereas in America we're like you'll
tell me what to do is America I've got
rights dammit I've got rights so how
much of that is cultural I there's a
significant part of it that is cultural
less so when it comes to those defense
mechanisms like denial and so forth
that's pretty you know a biological kind
of reality across the board but these
the comparison between a collective
society and an individualistic society
right the collective is more is less
than CERN about their own let's say
rights or privileges and it's more about
protecting the community whereas in
places like America it's it's
individualistic right and there's some
positive aspects to that you know we're
high achievers and the rest but when it
comes to something like a public health
crisis that could have very dire
consequences as we're seeing now right
it's it's who cares about your health
it's about me and my business
a legitimate concern right I have
economic concerns but that the weights
between the public good and the in the
good of the individual it's sort of a
little bit out of balance and so there
are these cultural differences and that
will is becoming apparent in terms of
the numbers right you know America is
doing compared to some other countries
so Heather we we went to our fan base to
collect questions and they knew the
topic and they know you so I think
they're more your fan base than ours
followed you so Chuck you got the
questions you know the drill that's
right we always start with a patreon
patron because they can give us money
and you know listen I'll do anything all
right let's start off with Lydia who
says dear Neal and Heather are there are
also positive sides during this pandemic
for mental health I can imagine that
some people now have more time to do
certain things they could not do before
and the result is a sense of
accomplishment mmm just to preamble that
I think I've noted this in my social
media Isaac Newton in 1665 escaped
London actually he was on in the
University of Cambridge University
Cambridge closed during the plague of
that year and he went to is his
childhood home in Lincolnshire and
that's when he made major advances in
our understanding of gravity and light
and mathematics and so this would be an
example of productivity going on
provided you have the right mindset in
the first place I suppose yeah so
Heather what can you say about people's
creativity productivity and the like
it varies you know there's no one
blanket answer for everyone it depends
some people's situation if you're
fortunate not enough to be in a
situation unlike myself having to care
for a three and six-year-old right now
you know it might be an opportunity to
for example you know I would love to
work on my book right now right and some
people do have the opportunity to do
that and they are you know using this
time this sort of that was given to them
in these productive ways but then others
feel the pressure right oh I should be
doing something productive and I'm not
and so it's a double-edged sword but I
do think and I'm finding this again with
patients is that some of them are using
this time to reset you know to take a
pause on they're always on the treadmill
rushing through their life and to say
you know what actually I want to work on
my mental health issues now I have the
time this is a really good opportunity
to work on myself now that we're on a
sort of a pause before I go back into
the rat race so people are using the
time I think in in in in positive ways
when they can right when they're not
struggling in other ways they can use it
to work on themselves or to work on a
project and again it also depends on how
long this time period lasts for even the
longer it goes on and then when a
frustration starts to build you know
there's only so much you can do and
after a while again we're we're almost
hitting that point here in the US where
people are like oh we want to get out we
want to get out but if you can find a
project to work on
I mean we're not all Isaac Newton Mia
what are you working on and of course
you did highlight at the beginning
discussion some positive gains for
people who were otherwise I'm antisocial
what's the term you have social anxiety
social exerting better yeah they don't
have the pressure to have to go out they
don't feel bad about staying in again
people with OCD feel validated they're
not alone so there are these positive
effects on mental health and people who
are you know are closer to their maybe
their children came home they came home
from college or spending more time with
their kids and that could be very
valuable and rewarding as well that can
also be a curse
so Chuck you got another one there yeah
we go let's go back to another patreon
patron this is jim marshall and jim says
hi Neil and Heather as a practicing
mental health counselor I am deeply
concerned by the level of anxiety I see
around me do you have any suggestions
for people to get the help and support
they need to weather this time
emotionally I'm gonna say Jim as a
practicing mental health counselor you
should already know the answer to that
know Jim Jim's asking for as as a public
service to the people who are listening
so it definitely well fortunately they
have lifted the restrictions I don't
know how long this is going to last for
so normally that's your licenses in the
state of New York to practice you can't
see patients via telehealth in
California but they've lifted those
state restrictions so now a mental
health professional can via telehealth
would be available to anybody across the
country so that really opens the
floodgates maybe people who normally
wouldn't have access to a mental health
professional now will have many more
options there also you know I work at a
hospital in Mount Sinai thing you know
it is in the heart of the pandemic and a
lot of the frontline workers are
experiencing severe mental health issues
given what they're exposed to every day
so they've provided all of these new
services for providing mental health
professionals to frontline workers you
know there's a number they can call so
people are aware of this issue and are
making changes to make mental health
professionals more available so Heather
forgive my ignorance or possible
ignorance in this question but I mean
how much training do you and others
really have regarding pandemics I mean
this is not an everyday thing you know
this is this is not all
but he loves me everybody hates me or
some other depressed state this is this
this doesn't really have precedent in
the current generation so we're asked
what what do you draw upon in your own
professional expertise to address this
yeah so it's true not everybody has the
toolkit to deal with the psychological
issues but you know at one level you
know anxiety is anxiety you know fear
uncertainty fear of a potential threat
whether it's because of the pandemic or
because you know you just lost your job
or whatever it may be the same tools to
apply but that being said you know
somebody who is who specializes say in
schizophrenia you might not be the best
therapist to treat the depression and
the social isolation and anxiety so it
does there are variations in terms of
therapists but they but when there is a
crisis it's sort of it's all hands on
deck you know so anybody who has some
sort of training it's better to have
something than nothing right and then
ideally you have a specialist who like
one of my specialties is anxiety so that
you know comes in handy right now but
again it's better to have something than
nothing and the rule is the in terms of
ethics you know who you are and aren't
allowed to treat in in non-emergent
times changes now so when there is a an
emergency and if somebody does not have
health care available or mental health
care available you are legally allowed
to treat them because that whole concept
something is better than nothing I'm
just shocked give me another one before
we go to break all right here we go this
is been to the gym on that's for Hamill
okay into the gym where do you live
because they're all closed here I he's
from Instagram and been to the gym says
what is it that people like myself
although feeling for those having had
hard times who are enjoying quarantine
while others are having a breakdown it
is it is it purely an environmental
thing growing up or does our biochemist
three play a role so been to the gym is
loving the quarantine and we will get
back to that after the bridge this is
Startalk star talk cosmic queries in the
corona verse mental health edition chuck
you just read a question from somebody
who's saying yo I love I'm loving it and
loving it like Barnes quarantine is like
McDonald's too many I'm lovin it
but he's he so Heather he raises a very
important point a nurturer nature
question is he loving quarantine holding
loss or jobs aside for the moment is his
reaction to quarantine something
biochemical or is it genetic is it
learned that where does he fit in the
spectrum of people's reactions right it
is partially biological so that we've
done you know Studies on resilience
looking at for example Israeli soldiers
who have experienced the same combat
situation some of which going on to
develop PTSD and others are fine and
there is there are some genetic
differences that actually make people
more resilient to hardship and always
you know those people who find that the
cups half full right that kind of
outlook on life and we find that even
when something really bad happens to a
person let's say they get into a
terrible car accident and lose their
legs if the person was a sort of
resilient sort of happy-go-lucky person
before the accident they'll have a
little bit of a down period and they'll
go right back up to where they were
before same thing is a person who tends
to be more depressed less resilient they
win the lottery great they'll have a
little blip of happiness and then they
ends up going right back to where they
were before so your your pre-existing
personality and that is biochemical and
genetic will respond to the
environmental circumstances in a very
predictable way so I'm sure that this
person has probably had hardships
previously in their life and I would I
would imagine that they also responded
in a Raziel
way so there are these biochemical
differences which is why those people
who have a genetic predisposition to
develop psychiatric illness this event
will trigger that mm-hmm
yeah you'd mentioned that earlier that
if you were just just living on the
threshold of that it could be a
precipitating force and in the symptoms
people were already we're experiencing
depression and anxiety again just can
exacerbate that so the this this
situation not the actual virus but the
the quarantine and the results of the
virus how were handling can expose
what's already there kind of pull the
pull the covers back you know like
exactly yeah I liken it to um you know
how they say they can vino veritas right
like when you drink it usually
exacerbates whatever emotion was already
there before so if you drink when you're
depressed you'll get more depressed if
you drink when you're celebrating you'll
be more you know exuberant and so this
is kind of like that it's enhancing what
was there before
yeah like before the quarantine I was
working approaching an a-cup and now
that the quarantine has been for eight
weeks I am a full B Cup
these are Corona blooms that I had I am
man boobs yes corona moobs interesting
what I think this is my prediction is
that as things start opening up
gradually as they're going to do in New
York little by little
it might actually increase people's
anxiety because the uncertainty like
right now we're sort of inner bubbles
we're kind of protected or allowed to
stay in our homes you know as we sort of
gradually go out and send maybe send our
kids to school in a kind of in a
socially distance way the uncertainty is
going to increase the anxiety I think
will increase in people and there might
be more even more mental health issues
in that in that new world is that
because when you're home you know you're
not and everyone who's been with you for
three weeks you know you're not going to
catch it but once society begins to open
there's at risk that you absorb but yeah
and and just just for those who are not
and fluent I'm obligated to say that
Heather's phrase in vino veritas is
specific translates to in wine there is
truth
so Heather specifically they're talking
about wine not beer or gin or whiskey
now it is why yeah it doesn't work with
Jack Daniels you never drink Jack
Daniels and tell anybody how you really
feel so I just want to clarify what you
said when you drink it's when you drink
wine yeah well on my mug it says Vera's
hot see maybe that's why I thought of it
true it's also the the motto of Harvard
University yeah I covered that up
because that seemed a little bit
obnoxious all right that's funny and let
me get my mug from Philadelphia College
just a quick aside because in vino
veritas which of course means you know
what we just talked about I think is
incorrect
I believe that alcohol can affect your
brain to the point where you would do
things that you otherwise would never do
or say you're not telling the truth as a
matter of fact your brain has been
altered by a substance that actually
alters your reality at the same time and
so you can get drunk enough where you'll
tell somebody that you hate them and you
don't hate them you know I'm glad to
differ hold on wait wait before you go
Heather Chuck thanks dad for that advice
when did you become a dad I don't know
about you drink Chuck but um know what I
would say to that is that we do have
these unconscious impulses and desires
and things that our prefrontal cortex is
normally suppressing when you drink if
it decreases activation the prefrontal
cortex it lowers your suppression so
what was actually there under the
surface you might not even if yourself
have been aware of is lingering under
the surface that comes out of us okay in
that dreams you know sometimes you're
this weird dream you say like why don't
you bet the person I don't really like
them but maybe somewhere inside of you
you do like them so I think that you're
even it's even revealing the truth to
yourself that you didn't know about so
Chuck you're saying you don't have time
for you the comedian to argue with the
mental health professional about why
she's wrong she's wrong I'm just saying
she's not considering the whole picture
even though she went to Harvard okay I
will say this you probably behaviors
that you engage in you wouldn't do it in
your normal life normally you would not
there are certain things you do that you
normally wouldn't do because they're
suppressed but when you release that
inhibition that they there you go okay
all right okay drinking exposes your
lizard brain that's what she's I just I
just summarized what she's yes exactly
but yeah however I'm going a little bit
deeper and saying that um that you can
you can drink enough where you would do
something that you would just never even
consider never get and see I'm speaking
from experience
okay here we go
here we go next question next question
next question this is from oh by the way
the last question that I mean in your
class description and you talked about
people becoming more anxious that was
let me just acknowledge that em ski art
from patreon had an upcoming question
that says I just want to know if we'll
be seeing a wave of agoraphobia once we
are reintroduced to society so you
actually answered this question in in
the last statements that you made just
want to point that out so you remind us
whether agoraphobia is agoraphobia is a
fear of leaving the house and I do think
that that will be an issue for a lot of
people going forward because of the
uncertainty so even when things do open
up it's not like people are suddenly
well maybe in certain places they will
flood or you know the restaurants and
bars but there will be a lot of segments
of people who still will self isolate
because of that uncertainty in a theorem
because there's still not a treatment or
a vaccine so I think there will be an
increase in the agoraphobia and if I
remember correctly the Agora is an open
space in ancient Rome your people
gathered and if you feared the open
space and people you were agoraphobic I
think that's the origin correct
yeah and that's like some people who are
afraid of being in malls or like big
open spaces that's kind of where it
originated because they would have a
panic attack
in the middle of it so they just stayed
home no I do up it's the opposite of
claustrophobia
[Laughter]
that was great no it isn't it's very
very terrible it's terrible yes here we
go
Frankie swanky from facebook says this
hello neo and dr. Berlin I'm coming to
you for some advice when the lockdown
began I was going through a breakup my
friends were telling me I need to get
the hell out of my apartment but now
that's impossible
what is some good advice to maintain a
healthy state of mind during all of this
psi you start off as a mental
stimulation you guys are great okay oh
the question himself actually well this
is a problem so part of the treatment
for a depression or like let's you're
getting over a breakup is what we call
behavioral activation it's the sort of
gold standard treatment so if somebody's
depressed and their lack of motivation
you actually like push them to go out
and do activities to break that cycle
now we're all stuck in the house so our
worlds have shrank but we can still
create these kind of mini worlds within
them so you can create novelty with
things you have around you right so we
mentioned like I use Startalk for my
mental stimulation right if you normally
always play a crossword puzzle like
switch to you know some other mental
activity learn to play chess the brain
likes novelty and change and that
releases dopamine which is a feel-good
chemical so even if our worlds are small
you know you can't jet set around the
world now and go to fun parties but you
can find activities within ours are
smaller worlds that are novel that will
give you that bit of dopamine so that is
like a behavioral activation we just
have to be more creative in that in that
endeavor it's not as easy as you know
it's not all provided for us in terms of
entertainment so that would be my bit of
advice yeah and here to people so
Heather in your professional practice
did you just say you're gonna start
recommending start talk but you just
said that Chuck didn't supersize I think
that's what I heard that's what I heard
we've got quite the back catalog too so
we've been at this for a while okay we
got time for one more I think all right
this is pilar bada from facebook and
pilar says this hi I'm a big fan chiming
in from Spain
yes pannier espana do you think that the
lack of sunlight and being indoors will
result in some mental health issues
I definitely feel it so to be clear in
New York City with a lot of tall
buildings and there's not much sunlight
vectoring into your place because the
outside your windows another building
you could be in broad daylight but still
be in darkness and I presume if you live
in a private home somewhere in the
suburbs or in a rural place daytime is
still daytime to you so really we're
talking about people who live in small
confined places with not much windowing
right so tell us about that the role of
the sunlight absolutely I mean sunlight
can affect your mental health we know
that actually one of the treatments for
depression is to people are not getting
enough sunlight or vitamin D is to get
one of those Sun lamps just to provide
that they sell those where you can put
it there by your desk and just to have
that natural light that affects our
neural chemistry everything that's
coming in through our senses affects
that the other thing I want to say
though is that will it just to be clear
that wait it's not just another light
it's a life that has the spectrum that
matches that of the Sun that's right so
that way you you you're perhaps you're
duping your body into thinking that it's
sunlight that's exposed to you and not
just some incandescent or fluorescent
bulb exactly because we've evolved with
that spectrum of light over many years
and so that affects our sleep/wake cycle
so if you ever had jetlag you know that
can really mess you up and it can
actually make you more more irritable
and and anxious right so it's affecting
our sleep cycles as well so you want to
make sure you have that natural
Lightwood sends a signal to the brain
like okay it's daytime now you should be
awake because that's another issue is
that like even though we're all inside
that to keep a regular schedule to have
times you know we you you're up during
the daytime and sleep at night unless of
course you have a job that is you know
doesn't allow that but is important for
our mental health to having national
sleep cycles but the other thing I want
to mention is that being indoors you
have a lack of stimulation right so you
obituaries see them day after day
because it's not novel and so what the
brain does we know this from sensory
deprivation studies is that it will
begin to stimulate itself when it lacks
stimulation you'll start to loosen eight
and then people also reporting having
more vivid dreams at night and not just
that they're also their anxiety seeps
into their dreams so people are having
corona type dreams for instance I've had
a dream where I all of a sudden I'm in a
mall and doing something and then all of
a sudden I realize wait I shouldn't be
around all these people I got to get out
of here what am I doing here get away
from me and I start running out of the
mall you know so your brain suddenly
realizes you know wait I shouldn't be so
so there's this increased anxiety but we
are having more dreams because of
stimulation so the overtime for this in
the dream I thought but wait how come
you didn't invite me to the party like I
caught her I snuck in and I caught her
but why wasn't I invited to the party
anyway that's a separate podcast so we
got to take a break before we go to our
third and final segment this is Startalk
when the karela village mental health
condition we'll be right back
we're back Startalk cosmic queries
coronavirus Mental Health Edition and
I've got with me Chuck nice as always
hey hey tweeting it just Chuck nice
comic thank you sir yeah and Heather
Berlin neuroscientist friend of Startalk
a therapist herself based at Mount Sinai
Heather always good to have you and you
can you've got a social media footprint
your your handle as well Heather
underscore Berlin on Twitter and how
about Instagram I am indeed and I
believe it's the same Heather underscore
Berlin you believe it's the same okay it
is the same I didn't know that Twitter
handles were belief systems it'd be so
funny though if it weren't the same and
that heather underscore berlin on
instagram started getting like questions
just some woman in the city of berlin
germany
oh my god wouldn't it be great just like
cause these Americans they asked so we
got another face in the mix here we've
got Gary O'Reilly Gary hey you just
crossed over you you're my co-host along
with Chuck for Startalk sports edition
yeah lineside rum just around a backdoor
and we thought we might devote this
segment to mental health and the corona
virus and the clean the corona verse but
as it might affect athletes and their
you know we're we're not seeing
athletics at this point because seasons
have been canceled or delayed and so we
might want to know what effect that has
so you have a question for Heather I do
right while athletes can exercise they
can do star jumps and press ups pushup
oh wait wait wait wait I must interrupt
okay we didn't just put the British
accent on here for the hell of it
there's a reason why you are my co-host
on sports edition Gary you are a former
professional athlete professional soccer
star in the UK
thank you yes I was and if you were to
look me up in the corona verse I would
probably be talking to someone like
Heather Berlin and step-ups in their own
lounge they can't be competitive and how
our athletes Heather please particularly
those that are involved in ball sport
games retain that superfast mental
processing speed that makes them on
occasion just phenomenal and if you're
locked out of your sport for this amount
of time are you gonna look at a
degradation of that kind of mental speed
or actually does it stick with you or
does it how long does it take all right
so look I mean a lot of you especially
if you play competitive sports um
the not having colleagues with you to
kind of help motivate you right and
which speeds up are you know which gives
us the kind of we need a goal to kind of
speed up you know your mental processes
however there are other ways that you
can keep that knife sharp so to speak
great so it's not just the physical
activity but if you can engage in
competitive mental tests I mean if
something as simple as you know video
games that involve competition you know
they have these we can wear a headset
and talk to other people who you're
playing with right so let's say a video
you know soccer game that you can play
with other people because to the brain
there isn't that much difference between
say virtual reality space and real space
you can very easily trick the brain so I
would recommend if you you want to keep
sharp to play these sort of competitive
sports virtually and that will engage
the same sort of mental circuits that
you would engage if you were actually
physically playing that's interesting
you know Heather I once hosted a spinoff
of Nova PBS Nova called Nova ScienceNOW
and one of our episodes was on
the retaining mental acuity and I was
trained up on a task it was some kind of
a arcade game alright and there I was
and I got better while I kept doing it
but I did it long enough so it was
really kind of in my head then I took a
break I actually took a nap and then I
came back and I was better than at any
time that I had left off and the
analysis was that my brain kept at that
exercise because I had gotten so
embedded in it that I ended up improving
not only my speed my reflexes and my
acuity so this is an interesting world
the brain that you spend it's called
it's called consolidation and so that's
why actually when you're studying for an
exam or practicing a physical activity
sleep is so important breaks are so
important because you have the period of
time when your brain is stirred in
taking the information it's learning and
learning and learning from acquiring the
information but then you need during the
rest periods are just as important
because there are other neural processes
that consolidate it and and we do find
this after people sleep there's a spike
in performance they do better and then
after a while you know fatigue sets in
and the rest and you can start to train
drain off so learning it that's also for
an exam cramming for exam is not great
you want to space it out you'll do
better on the exam because you have
these periods of consolidation but let
me get back to Gary's point he was
specifically referencing what role a
competitor has on your own urge to excel
rather than just people urging you know
cheering you on right so that was a
different saying it's why anyone would
set a world record they just ran or
performed better than they ever have in
their life better than anyone ever has
in that moment how many world records
are ever set by someone doing something
on their own
I bet near zero so in Gary's case so
Gary what I wonder is if you can train
the mind to have a mental acuity Heather
does that really translate into
biokinetic acuity or speeds
just training the minds we train the
mind can that make your body faster is
that that's like that's it Gary is that
a fair part of your question I think you
know what we I would sorry Heather cuz
now I'm taking your role in this in this
conversation I would I would put that
under the file confidence if I believed
that I have this confidence that I'm
sharp mentally my there's a wrestling
term get the head and the body will
follow near remember I think this is
another example of that yeah I you know
I think it comes down also its
motivation its motivation and then
belief right so you know we talked about
self-fulfilling prophecies right if you
think you're going to fail you'll be
more likely to fail you kind of psych
yourself out right if you think you're
going to succeed that's why the
visualization especially for athletes is
so important like I'm gonna make that
goal I can see it I'm going to do it so
it's that the the body will follow
as long as it's trained and it actually
knows what to do so a lot of it is you
know getting yourself out of the way
getting your doubts and and and you know
self doubt out of the way to allow your
body to do what it was trained to do but
if it's not physically trained to do
that or let's say you've been in
quarantine you haven't actually
practiced for a while you know you still
won't even if you can of all the mental
motivation in the world you won't be
able to actually enact that if your
muscles haven't you know stayed up to
part like say so I think you need
obviously need both it's not one or the
other but the point is that if you're at
home and you're an athlete and you're
practicing your physical you know
keeping up with your physical activities
it's just as important to also keep up
with that mental activity with the
competitive sports the competitive games
let's say and and the drive and the
motivation that comes from many
different places some people have
internal motivation for their own
reasons some people need the competitor
to have that level of motivation so that
will vary so Gary you have more
questions for further I have a mind full
of questions just this one foot for
Heather
now that certain leagues are coming back
we're sort of mid May here and the
German soccer league the Bundesliga is
the first out of the gates with games
starting in empty Stadium NASCAR will
return later this month so in my mind
and how they please because they
is an interesting one for me will
athletes react differently a within the
racist drivers but for instance soccer
or basketball how are they going to
react to being in an empty stadium and
having no reaction from the crowd to
imagine I do the most incredible trick
or move and enormity I get an
instantaneous Wow this rush of energy
comes to particularly personally to me
that's no longer there how our athletes
going to react to that empty Chuck the
same question applies to you what's it
like being in a nightclub not that this
will happen but just you can imagine it
you got a stand-up routine in a
nightclub and nobody is at any of the
cocktail tables does that work pretty
well for me yeah it works because
nobody's laughing when there are believe
it or not I'm still doing comedy zoom
now and you know we get like a hundred
two hundred people that caught that
chimed in to these comedy shows to check
out comedians just trying out material
and doing stuff and you know it's for me
personally my jokes and people say this
too they're like oh you laugh at your
own jokes and I'm like yeah that's cuz
I'm funny
okay how about yes suck it okay because
I don't care that comedians aren't
supposed to laugh at their jokes I do
most of my comedy for me believe so you
have comedians and athletes which the
same challenge if you have to perform
without a live audience so Heather where
what role does that play would you say
yeah so again similar phenomena I'm
thinking about these late-night
talk-show hosts that are now doing these
monologues without the audience feedback
even somebody who's observing it
watching it it feels a little awkward
right because of the timing so you know
we often go through this process of it's
very kind of Darwinian of like
performance feedback revision right and
so we're performing and they were
looking or for that feedback whether
positive or
that then helps us kind of revise our
performance and then we can either get
it from the players that were playing
with but a lot of the audience them
input helps look let's say you're
running down the field to get a goal and
now the audience is cheering and
cheering and cheering you on that's
gonna make you run even faster and that
we call that in Psychological terms
social facilitation so we find that
certain people's performance is enhanced
simply by being observed by people but
that depends on what the task is so
that's if it's a simple task like
running as the test gets more complex
then you get the opposite effect you get
what we call social inhibition which is
that your performance can get worse if
you're being observed depending on the
completed task is very complex so it's
it's a mixed bag but I think in general
with sports the audience feedback
usually facilitates right it gives you
more of motivation to keep running or go
that extra mile and we are going to lose
that I feel like the sports are going to
be slightly less aggressive perhaps
slightly less competitive because
there's not that motivational factor of
the live audience viewing it but you
know the truly competitive player is
going to flourish in that scenario
somebody like a Tom Brady who doesn't it
doesn't care who's watching I just need
to kill you I need to beat you at all a
Michael Jordan type like I don't I just
heard a story of Michael Jordan in
practice want a player on his team
blocked his shot and then for the rest
of the practice Michael Jordan actually
dribble around people to go to that
player a player like that will flourish
under the circumstances you just said
and also actually there are certain
players who and usually I mean people
who professional sports players have
figured out ways to overcome this but
certain players have a bit of social
anxiety so actually you know performing
in front of an audience is harder for
them they have to learn how to block it
out and focus and so they might also do
better without the audience there as a
distractor
so so it is it is a mixed bag you know
to playing on a player how internally
motivated they are and how much they're
impacted by the audience okay Gary we're
running a little simple on time you got
one last question how long does live
sport have to be off the menu before
fans lose their sports addiction oh
because we know sports addicted people
and you know that that that subject is
so tasty mm-hmm that I want to save that
for a star talk sports edition yeah yeah
let's let's let's port that over to
Startalk sports edition if you want to
get the full answer to that and Heather
you're gonna join us for sports edition
as well will you phone again Heather
you're not supposed to psychoanalyze the
hosts worked sports edition so we gotta
call it quits there so Heather
Gary Chuck we're gonna I'm gonna pick
you up over in sports edition yeah if we
can port everyone over to that side of
the house and in the meantime I'll just
say goodbye to the three of you in this
cosmic queries dark talk in the corona
verse Mental Health Edition and like I
said Heather it's always great to have
you all right I am Neil deGrasse Tyson
your personal astrophysicist as always
[Applause]
[Music]